[Music]
on this wednesday night bc declares a
state of emergency
we had more rain in two days than we
normally get an entire november fears a
critical pumping station could fail
the people defying merits evacuation
order and the lengths farmers are going
to try to save their livestock the added
strain on the supply chain what if we
run out of medication new difficulties
getting goods in and out of bc
attention cross-border shoppers and day
trippers when pcr tests will likely be
scrapped for short visits to the us
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us a
state of emergency has now been declared
in bc as thousands of people remain
displaced from their homes and
communities cut off by catastrophic
flooding the power of the water driven
by climate change has devastated lives
and wiped out critical infrastructure
the federal government is now sending
the military in to assist with
evacuations and the supply chain chaos
as bc deals with disasters on multiple
fronts premier john horgan says the
state of emergency is needed to help
everyone get access to water food and
shelter
the order will preserve basic access to
services and supplies for communities
across the province
we will bring in travel restrictions and
ensure that transportation of essential
goods and medical and emergency services
are able to reach the communities that
need them
here are some of the worst hit places in
abbotsford 75 kilometers southeast of
vancouver more than 180 people were
rescued by air and water overnight there
is fear a critical pumping station could
fail putting more people and hundreds of
farms at risk hundreds of animals have
already died
over the last two days i've been able
to have um
facetime
discussions with farmers and some of
them are in their barns
and some of their barns are flooded
and you can see the animals that are
deceased
and it's heartbreaking
northeast of there the city of merit is
still a no-go zone the flood water is
dropping but the water and sanitation
systems have failed and it will be some
time before they're repaired and near
lillauet the search continues for those
missing since a mudslide swept vehicles
off highway 99 three hours north of
vancouver police have recovered the body
of one woman
there is lots to get to tonight our
coverage begins with robin gill in
abbotsford
when their livelihoods are at risk
farmers are willing to risk their lives
to save their animals not leaving until
as many as possible are safe thousands
of animals have already died others will
have to be put down yeah we moved 150
cows yesterday john cetzman knew he had
to step in to help his neighbors the
worst year for farming we went from
drought to high water to this like the
hands down the worst year for farming
the flooding has forced hundreds of
people in abbotsford bc from their homes
some airlifted out others left to get
out on their own i had to go the back
way and around barriers and i had to
leave my id with a police officer and i
had half an hour to get in get my stuff
and get out again
we were literally just throwing stuff
because we don't know for how long this
part of abbotsford is known as sumas
prairie the hub of british columbia's
agriculture sector but these once
bucolic fields are now underwater two
rivers the fraser in british columbia
and the nucsac in washington state are
putting pressure on the city's pump
station
protected by sandbagging efforts
stretching late into the night it can
pump over half a million gallons of
water but that's meant for only one
river while the situation remains
critical at this time the barrel town
pump station
is operating at its full capacity but
was never intended or designed to take
on water from another country all that
farmland is under about 3.5 meters of
water there are sandbags around the pump
station but the city of abbotsford is
simply buying time tonight a full moon
is rising and that could raise the tide
of the rivers nearby the government of
bc is declaring a state of emergency
bc's premier who's been undergoing
cancer treatment is addressing the
emergency the last few days have been
incredibly difficult
for british columbians as we've
experienced yet another natural disaster
susan gillis is relying on the kindness
of strangers for now not knowing when
she can go home how are you coping in
all of this
poorly
but as best as i can you know i try to
keep things calm for everyone else as
for the farmers they're working around
the clock to try to save their animals
for a bad situation it turned out very
well but not for every farm and there's
still so much uncertainty robin gill
global news abbotsford bc
there is still so much uncertainty this
is a dairy and poultry farm in sumas
prairie it's completely inundated
including the chicken barn and the
milking barn i spoke with matt dykeshorn
who runs the farm with his family
how many chickens did you lose matt
uh probably between 20 and 25 000.
wow that's half half your barn
yeah and you sent us some pictures uh or
your sister did i think of
some calves in the kitchen
uh it was actually my barn office
that was literally the only dry place
that i could put i went out to check
them monday night at 9 30
and they were standing shoulder deep in
water
i did not i did not know how long
the water would keep rising
so i threw them in the heated office and
they've been hanging out there ever
since well it's got to be incredibly
stressful for all these animals
oh for sure they they have no idea
what's going on they're hungry they're
looking for a place to lay down
they're they're standing at the gate
balling at me and which is a pretty
helpless feeling because they're
literally nothing i can do for them well
matt i'm so sorry for everything you're
going through thank you for
for taking us through
what's happening to your farm
rescuers are scouring a mudslide on
highway 99 between pemberton and
lillewet for more victims one woman has
been confirmed dead and today bc premier
john horgan said more fatalities are
expected at least two other people have
been reported missing logs mud and
damaged vehicles still litter the
roadway crews clearing the debris say
the pavement underneath appears to be
intact
in south central bc in the city of merit
an evacuation order remains in place
though some people never left part of
that city of 7 000 is still under water
and rcmp have stepped up their patrols
heather urix west is at one of the
police checkpoints heather is there any
timeline on when the evacuation order in
merit might be lifted
well donna we spoke with city officials
today who say they're working as fast as
they can but it still could be another
week before people here are allowed to
return home the problem though as you
mentioned there are hundreds of people
who never left and that the city says is
making cleanup efforts more complicated
days after flooding forced the
evacuation of an entire city much of
merit bc remains under water though
residents are anxious to return we have
dogs and stuff so the hotel doesn't work
that good and i just told them they had
to let us back in and they did outside
city hall evacuees like joe sales have
come back to plead their case hoping for
a wristband that would allow them to
pass through the rcmp checkpoints
limiting access to the city the city of
merit is quiet but it's not empty
despite the evacuation order officials
estimate about a thousand residents have
decided to stay behind they're living in
a community without water sewage or
access to groceries and other supplies
we cannot bring citizens back as long as
we have unsafe water and no access to
our waste water system so
that is our number one priority is to
ensure that the water is safe for our
residents and that
they can come home and flush toilets and
use water
with an evacuation order expected to
remain in effect for at least a week
officials are asking all remaining
residents to pack up and go across the
cold water river the city says accessing
the neighborhood of colletteville is no
longer safe we had to decide we weren't
going to risk the lives of firefighters
and ambulance crews by sending heavy
vehicles over those bridges as a result
anyone who is still in collettville has
no emergency services available to them
but collettville residents like cal jade
are undeterred determined to remain in
the community as long as they can we've
got camping gear that we're using and
because we're in a construction zone
there are portable like toilets like
porta potties so that people have been
using those
on tuesday a family who stayed behind
had to be rescued from the air the lower
mainland's north shore rescue crew says
the family of three and their dog were
brought to safety after flowing water
surrounded their home a reminder that
for this community the emergency is not
over yet
and with so many properties here
unattended evacuees have had some
concerns that their homes could be
targeted by thieves that's why the city
says that as of this morning rcmp have
doubled its presence here they are
patrolling the entire city including
that cut-off community of collettville
on the other side of the river donna
okay heather yorick's west in merit
british columbia thanks with so many
highways washed out thousands of people
are stranded more than one thousand are
stuck in hope at the eastern end of the
fraser valley about two hours east of
vancouver global's camel caramalli is
there tonight camel what are you hearing
from people who have been stranded now
since monday
donna a small and usually quiet airport
packed with people today looking to pay
thousands of dollars for private
helicopters and small planes to take out
of hope right now it's the only way out
of the district
the desperation to leave partially due
to the dwindling resources here with
both routes north on the coquihalla and
west on highway 7 completely blocked
some people have been hoarding goods and
supplies empty shelves at grocery stores
with some completely running out of eggs
milk and bottled water there are also
concerns for people running out of
medicine only a handful of pharmacies
here and they're running short on
medication limiting the number of doses
they can give to people while others
have more complex medicinal needs and
are desperately in need of access to
pharmacies in vancouver we met one
mother who's five-month-old has a very
rare heart condition and needs her
supplies back in coquitlam or her son's
health will deteriorate quickly his
heart is unpredictable i just need to be
at home like it's so hard to tell like
it could be
it could not happen he could be totally
fine or it could happen tonight and we
need to get out and
and that's scary now those people who
have been choosing to fly out of hope
have been leaving their cars abandoned
here at the airport but those who want
to drive out of the district well they
have not received any clear indication
when that may be it could be as long as
weeks from now donna kamal karamali in
hope british columbia
the provincial government says getting
highways repaired and open is one of its
top priorities highway 7 west of agassi
is now open to single lane alternating
traffic in some other areas the washouts
are so extensive it could take months to
repair officials say the best hope for
restoring a key route soon as highway 3
it snakes along the southern part of the
province the coca hall of the main
connector and fastest route between
vancouver and kelowna and kamloops is
another story the province says five
sections of that whole highway are badly
damaged some parts including bridge
sections are snapped off and washed away
cn and cp rail lines are also washed out
and all of this is having a devastating
effect on canada's already fragile
supply chain the port of vancouver the
largest in canada is now cut off from
the rest of the country abigail beeman
reports on how the impacts of the bc
storm will soon be felt by the rest of
the country
i went in for a few things and realized
there wasn't much of anything hollowed
out grocery store shelves like these in
kelowna just one challenge
everything hangs on how long it will
take to rebuild rail and road i had a
load of lumber was taken into vancouver
but
everything got closed it flooded out and
everything so
we had just turn around come back
lumber loads may wait perishables cannot
dairy farmers already told to dump milk
unable to be picked up on the supply
side the situation is quite
catastrophic sylvan charlevoix says food
shortages will largely be felt within bc
we could see sources of butter in the
area
yogurt
sour cream ice cream
in a few weeks from now which would be
unfortunate because it would be a few
weeks before the holidays then there's
the larger supply chain issue getting
goods from bc out to the rest of the
country and beyond with no estimate on a
fix to the rail system it's
certainly been heavily damaged all rail
service to the port of vancouver is down
that's canada's biggest port moving as
much as 70 percent of container goods
for now ships are anchored waiting but
there's a capacity limit which the
chamber of shipping expects will soon be
reached this is going to delay exports
of canadian commodities it's going to
delay parts coming in for manufacturing
processes in other parts of canada this
is coming on top of the already existing
supply chain challenges that have been
created by covet so it's just sort of
one thing after another overall impacts
could include everything from getting
prairie grain to asia is seen as a
reliable supplier of food and it's
important we keep that reputation to
getting goods of all kinds into canada
consumer electronics for christmas
anything you're thinking about that
would have uh imports from the pacific
region
there are likely to be shortages and
there are likely to be price increases
for anything that does manage to get
through most pervasive is the
uncertainty of it all with no one not
trans mountain nor cp nor cn yet saying
exactly how long these repairs will take
it's impossible to know the extent of
the impact
donna abigail beeman in ottawa thanks a
change is coming for canadians wanting
to make a quick trip to the u.s that's
coming up after the break
a change is coming to the covet 19
testing requirements for canadians
coming back into canada from the united
states it's expected a pcr test will no
longer be required for those who make
short trips to the u.s border
restrictions are among the issues prime
minister justin trudeau is discussing on
a trip to washington our chief political
correspondent david aiken is traveling
with the prime minister
[Music]
once prime minister justin trudeau
touched down in america's capital he
like every canadian who comes here
requires a clean pcr test proving he
doesn't have covid before he can go home
it's one of the key restrictions canada
put in place when it reopened its border
in the summer fully vaccinated canadians
can return to canada without having to
quarantine but that pricey pcr test is
required within three days of arriving
at the border
that testing requirement though is seen
as an unnecessary impediment to travel
and many here in the u.s and back in
canada think it ought to be dropped but
we really need to have the government
follow the advice of their own expert
panel immediately and remove the pcr
requirement
common sense requires it
well it may soon be global news has
learned that the government is set to
announce perhaps as early as friday that
it will in fact drop the pcr test
requirement but only for fully
vaccinated canadians who have been gone
less than 72 hours so that's good for
those who want to do some cross-border
shopping or see a sporting event or a
concert in the u.s but the entry
requirement is expected to remain for
all foreign nationals including
americans and for canadians out of the
country longer than three days the
question that the the government will
have to answer is
how are you safe
in the 72nd hour and you become
dangerous in the 73rd
what is the logic of this the prime
minister of canada trudeau wouldn't say
much about the new border rules we are
looking at
making making steps to
to loosen up requirements while at the
same time keeping canadians safe but he
did talk privately about them with
congressional leaders like nancy pelosi
and kevin mccarthy chuck schumer and
mitch mcconnell
other border management issues and
rising u.s protectionism were also on
the agenda on thursday the leaders will
get down to business and they'd say
they'll be looking to craft a north
american strategy to deal with covet in
the economy to deal with climate change
and to deal with chyna donna okay david
aiken in washington dc thanks
queen elizabeth back to her royal duties
that's coming up
[Music]
one of the most recognizable riders from
the january sixth attack on the u.s
capitol has been sentenced to 41 months
in prison jacob chansley stormed the
building wearing a horned hat and face
paint he was among the first riders to
disrupt lawmakers meeting to certify
president joe biden's election he
pleaded guilty to obstructing an
official proceeding he is among 650
people charged after the riot
queen elizabeth is back on her feet
today she carried out her first
in-person engagement in a month
she met with the head of britain's armed
forces who is due to step down at the
end of november one of the queen's
beloved dogs was there too the 95 year
old had been following doctor's orders
to rest since spending a night in the
hospital last month on sunday she didn't
attend the national remembrance service
because the palace said she'd sprained
her back
the canadian men's soccer team
celebrated their second goal against
mexico last night canadian style they
beat mexico two to one in a pivotal
world cup qualifier it was a nail-biting
and exciting win on the road to the
world cup and as eric sorenson reports
an historic night for canadian soccer
november in edmonton freezing
temperatures surrounded by snow
welcome mexico with an icy home field
advantage the mexicans coping with the
cold canada beat the ninth ranked team
in the world before a boisterous
edmonton crowd the nation is being drawn
to men's soccer like never before
atmosphere here in the stadium was
electric yeah it's something special i
haven't seen anything like this canada
had not even qualified to play in this
tournament of the best caribbean north
and central american teams since 1998
canada began the night in third place
the win vaults this country over mexico
and the united states into first place
for the first time the top three go to
next year's world cup even the players
seem surprised canada is top of the
group if you said that in the beginning
here i would have said what group just
because we're talk right now doesn't
mean anything to us we still have so
much more that we want to accomplish
superstar alfonzo davies and others have
led the team on the field but a lot of
credit goes to their english coach john
herdman ten years ago he helped build
the canadian women's team into one of
the top programs and four years ago took
over the men's team unifying the raw
talent and fostering a new winning
attitude they've built a foundation here
that they'll fight and they'll work for
each other
and when that's there the talent comes
out obviously the star power having the
star power helps but that star power is
now committed to helping the national
team that's because of the environment
that john herman has created is a sort
of honorary canadian now these uh
these are some of the best moments of my
life canada had hoped to qualify for the
2026 world cup that this country will
co-host but the team has blossomed so
quickly an unforeseen moment in canadian
sport may be at hand by next spring a
2022 world cup birth we keep pushing
ourselves to get better and better eric
sorensen global news toronto
such a great game and that is global
national for this wednesday i'm donna
friesen tonight's your canada is one
snowy chilly day at sturgeon creek in
winnipeg i remember it well we'd love to
see your canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]